he is the lineal heavyweight champion of
the world getting set to fight Tom
Schwartz in Las Vegas Nevada on a couple
of Saturdays from now he is none other
than Tyson Fury good to see you sir good
morning sir I'm doing better for talking
to you I'm very a stick that's what I
aim to do is please not you do it you
definitely are pleasing right now I'm
we're on the radio as well as television
Tyson and I'd love to describe to the
radio audience what what how would you
describe the shirt that you're wearing
right shirt is an LA style
pimp shirt and I have got the long slim
and slender tanned legs on show you this
morning I appreciate that maybe should
hold them up a little bit but we're
gonna be okay you know what it's it's
still a little early in the morning you
know out here in Los Angeles maybe a
little bit later in the afternoon I do
like the the the shorts choice as well I
didn't get the girl's wing yeah yeah
have have have they winked here in Los
Angeles have they real girls and guys
everybody that's you know it's that time
of year some fall times this morning
already on the way well it is great to
see you here let's I guess start with
the fight that you're taking on against
Tom Schwartz this uh in a couple of
Saturdays from now what are you what are
you expecting out of Tom in this fight
here
Tom's a young one beaten Prospectus 24
now number two in the world by the WBO
I'm expecting a tough fight hmm I never
overlooked my opponents and especially
someone not as good-looking as Tom
Schwartz you know this guy must have a
point to prove he's coming all the way
here it's lineal Championship on the
line he's coming he's coming from Jason
big rivalry you know Germany versus
England in any sports is massive rival
so we all both want to win it's all on
the line and what can I say may the best
man win okay and so obviously it should
you get past Tom as you expect no doubt
we never can tell come because we seen
last Saturday night right exactly so
that's no friends are given okay okay I
was gonna go to the next spot but since
you stopped right there and Anthony
Joshua what do you think of Joshua's
lost there Tyson well um dear as a win
was amazing
for it an absolutely
spots right there I like that you went
you went Ramon salutely over the moon
for undie couldn't happen to a nicer guy
mm-hmm how long have you known him I've
not I don't know him personally I've
kept an eye on his career career right
so um do you not want to talk about
Anthony Joshua through that response
it's not what I do water man has just
been flattened so lame of a little bear
dignity without me ripping him okay on
TV well I did I did notice your tweet
was was very kind and it was to a kind
treat but then I destroyed him in the
media that's why I'm trying to figure
out where you were like illogical wolf a
building smash him down yeah I mean
we're showing the tweet on the screen
right here we have our back-and-forth
but Anthony Joshua changed his stars
through life heavyweight boxing these
things happen rest up recover regroup
and come again you give him a little
fist pound emoji yeah and then you
figuratively fist pounded him in the
media yesterday yes well-deserved as
well because you know what if it was me
fat guy
yeah yeah and they'd destroy me he's
promoter on him would not leave off with
me and I thought you know what I'm being
too kind dear well I've been so kind to
people who have slated me my whole
career people who have been begging for
me to lose on every fight over Rob and
it just goes to show a bodybuilding
ain't boxing stick to your own sport and
leave the fights to the fighting men so
I asked this fighting man looking at
Joshua one of the things that many
observers are commenting on was his
reaction to losing where he did not seem
to take it very hard and he was smiling
taking photographs with Ruiz and when he
was in fact counted out it wasn't
hopping mad or anything like that what
what do you take out of that reaction a
lot of it to be on the [ __ ] well he was
happy to lose I think when people have a
lot of pressure on them and they build a
big record on a big reputation sometimes
they're happy just to get it out the way
that first loss I don't I don't know
what was going through the guy's mind
because I'm not inside of his head
mm-hmm
but
I can't understand what was going on can
you tell as a fighter when another
fighter gives up yes
do you think that happened laundry
person he didn't want to continue the
referee you know when I got put down and
round trial by Wilder I had to convince
the referee that I was able to fight on
I held him on both shoulders and I said
I'm okay he went yeah I said yes I'm
okay to continue and jog to the left a
job to the left jog to the right a jog
to the right I have to prove I was
willing to fight AJ just holding on to
the rope so he's too big eyes open like
that
mm-hmm saying yeah I'm okay but holding
onto ropes he didn't show any signs of
wanting to continue they don't even ever
see didn't even have his mouthpiece and
he didn't even just he was struggling
with a mouthpiece the whole night it's
at Tyson Fury here on the Rich Eisen
show let us I'm just fascinated by how
you got up from the the floor got up
from the the depths of where you were
against Deontay Wilder okay and that's
just one of the most remarkable images
I've seen in sports in a long time yeah
where you got up from the mat okay what
were you thinking were you were you with
it for all 10 seconds he came around
after about 4 seconds and open the eyes
obviously realize the foam on the Floria
get up mmm so I got up the thing with me
is is I always say it's quite easy to
beat me you've got knocked me down and
nail me to that canvas because if you
don't I'll continue to fight if this
announcer breath left in my body were
unable to get up and fight I'm not
knocked out cold then I'll continue to
fight on because that's me I won't be
the man I am today if I was gonna quit
if I were didn't want to fight on
anymore you know you meet you meet
people in life and you have different
obstacles that we try and get over ball
at the end of the day it's it's the
fight in the person so you were out for
4 seconds yeah you
come - right there in the middle of
staples here in downtown LA and it dawns
on you I need to get up within six
seconds yeah and it took you how many
seconds not very long I'll just jump
straight back home okay what do you say
to people that say it took you seven
seconds to get up after that for I don't
say much to him because it's not really
their call is it they're not the referee
or anybody else so it was what it was
but what what do people say to the fact
that I want 10 out 12 rounds and God
roll what they gotta say about that the
Delta Ripper a Manoff who's been to hell
and back struggle with mental health at
free air out the ring on drugs and
alcohol come back and kick the
everywhere champion in the world ass all
over LA and Staples Center and you have
to rob a man who's been down and out to
get a victory or hold on to something a
lot of people gotta say about that Tyson
Fury here on the Rich Eisen show where
do you find that reserve where does that
come from do you think he comes from
deep down within my soul a true bread
born fighting man who never quits never
says die and if I was ever gone a jacket
he wouldn't have been in a boxing ring
it had been when I was so from a mental
health I was on the verge of suicide
that's one other quit but I think quite
on me self and I think quit on the world
that's why I'm back here to tell the
story well we have a lot of folks who
take in this show listening watching who
whenever the subject of mental health
comes up they sit up straight because
there's so many people that are
struggling with mental health aside and
and it's and it's something that you
can't identify because there's no caste
there's no crutch it's just something
that goes on between the temples of
somebody and I have and you have no idea
what somebody's struggling with what do
you say to people who are right now
listening to you and maybe knowing your
story or not to those people to have
them get off the mat you know life salt
muffins ever gotten eight years hard as
life will and anyone who suffers with
mental health problems it is a silent
killer kills more people every year than
most of the things of men number 35 it's
the biggest killer on earth
and I was no different you know you
thinking have you a champion of the
world dives on top of everything he must
be happy right but that wasn't the
wasn't a day that I woke up I didn't
pray for death you know I had everything
to be happy for by every day was gray
and dark and my problem was I come from
a big are tough family you know one
communicates and no one shows weakness
if you show type of weakness it means
you're a weak person where I come from
so I was stuck between all of that
bravado and family peer pressure and
everything didn't know what to do so I
just didn't tell anybody about it
until one day I exploded and I couldn't
I couldn't continue anymore and I had to
seek help immediately and I do think not
the most important thing with anyone who
suffers a mental health is communication
without communication with others we're
not going to get better but I do promise
anybody who's listening
anybody who's suffering that it will get
better and there is gonna be sunshine
days once again because I've been there
I've woke up every day and I felt
terrible and there is no pinpoint
accuracy and what causes this problem
because if we knew we just wouldn't do
that thing that's caused it and move on
you can't tell someone to pull herself
together and get up and do it because
that just puts you in a deeper hole so
how can you help somebody identify where
rock-bottom is where you decided to make
that choice
Theisen me I was on the way to your
bridge 260 miles an hour and
high-performance car and I was wondering
percent certain this was a day that I
was going to end it all 2016 28 years
old I was home defeated world
heavyweight champion I'm on a one-way
ticket to death and just before I ate
this bridge I had a voice in my mind say
don't do this hmm this is not what are
you gonna do because think about your
kid's gonna grow up with no father
everyone's gonna say you're a weak
person no and I pulled the car over
immediately and I'll shake
and I called for help immediately father
came and collected me and I said listen
I said this what's going on
I need help immediately I can't do it on
my own and I went and got help
I went saw some doctors and I went to
counseling twice a week and we got over
it and without the help of a cloche
Union and I'm doctors as well I wouldn't
be here today that's for sure you know
only 18 months ago the only place I ever
envisioned ever be was in a padded room
maybe that was the best place I think I
could have been I definitely thought I
was gone a lost my mind and I really
believed that I was going to end up in a
padded room and it was a terrifying
fault to the fact of I wasn't gonna go
there because I was gonna kill myself
before I ever made it there Wow and
thank God you know you're sitting here
today and repair some do you battle
every day still or mental health some
people say to me I do all our light
shows and travel around the Europe and
stuff doing these and talk shows and
stuff right people come and speak and
whatever and every the question I
usually get is how did you defeat mental
health and I stand up and smile and I
say look mental health you never can
beat it ever there's no there's no
victory over mental health I like in
mental health to a famous song that the
Eagles roped Hotel California and
there's a famous person there and it
says you can check out anytime you want
but you can never leave you'll never
leave right and that's what mental
health is about you can check out
anytime you want you can get better
again but it will never leave you ever
you just got to learn to maintain and
manage what was suffering with you know
yesterday I felt terrible today before I
felt okay and I maybe I would have had a
a couple of weeks where I've been
feeling good bull you know there wasn't
a day go by that I'm not afraid to go
back to where I was only a short period
of time ago so it is a terrifying fault
but maybe talking about it as obviously
as freely as you do
is helpful and I know it I'm sure we're
gonna be looking at our Twitter feed or
our phone line after you've departed
from people saying that was awesome to
hear from Tyson because I have the same
issue I know somebody who has the same
issue I know a family member has the
same issue yeah and that's got to
hopefully be helpful for you wonderful
oh I didn't understand I'd suffered with
this my whole life from being a little
kid I didn't understand doubt I just
thought growing up a father was a
worthless piece of rubbish and I didn't
deserve to be I just felt like
everything I did in my life was rubbish
nothing I had ever achieved was any good
to me I felt like it was just all
pointless and I was a young kid I used
to suffer with anxiety and I never
understood until the year or two ago
what I was going through but you know
struggling in life is one thing but
struggling in your own mind is a whole
different level but I'm living proof but
we can get better because if you just
saw me 18 months ago I was over 400
pounds in weight I was heart attack
material I can't bend down and tie my
own shoelaces up without being out no
kidding honestly I couldn't jog half a
mile and now you're getting set to to
fight Tom Schwartz in a massive 18
months I've turned my life around and
I'm back to the top of the sport that I
left for three years and abused me body
for three years continuously so if I can
do I'm not no special human being I'm
just a normal man made of blood and bone
and if I can come back from all those
things then so can you so can everybody
else you struggle in there is light at
the end of the tunnel and I'm living
proof that he it is possible Tyson Fury
here on the Rich Eisen show before I let
you go obviously Deontay Wilder
announced this week he's going to take
on Luis Ortiz again sometime in
September's when everyone is expecting
it to be and then he said hey
I'm all set to fight Tyson Fury again
but you or no one from your campus
confirm that or said anything about that
can you say anything I can't say
anything look he's talking about a fight
that's a year away anything can happen
we're not promised tomorrow so I live
for today because the background I come
from and what I've been suffering with I
can't look at in advance too far I never
looked past it today because tomorrow I
might be in a total depression again so
I only have to live for today and be
happy for now and that's that's how I
get free ball Jonte wells talking about
fights is happening in 2020 I even fault
my fun Saturday yet cool get knocked out
not one we never count her chickens
before they are ch so if if you beat
Schwartz then you're willing to discuss
that or you need to see what he's gonna
do against Ortiz or nothing's given in
life nothing will not promised anything
so he has to get past Ortiz I'm probably
gonna fight again in september/october
you have to get through that do you know
against who I don't know okay see like I
say I don't go involved in it too much
one I've got a fight on the horizon I
don't I don't want past that first
initial fight well you've got a millions
of fans sir including everybody right
here in our studio Chris you were at
that fight in Los Angeles um that was it
was quite the spectacle I did not think
you were gonna get up all due respect
sir thank you and yet you did and here
you are just got to keep proving wrong
when people say it's not possible to do
it is possible nothing's impossible
I've been wrote off my whole life I've
always been this chubby fat kid whole
career struggle with weight problems
baloney or not I used to put on 140
pounds nearly after every fight and
enough to go into training come to get
it off again and it was like when am I
ever gonna learn not to keep doing this
to myself
nothing's easy but if you want it enough
you can do it anything is possible
Tom Schwartz vs. Tyson Fury 12 rounds
unless you make short work of him before
all that I already make short work
vice-versa I appreciate you you know you
taking both sides of the coin here MGM
Grand Garden Arena and beautiful Las
Vegas Nevada on Saturday June 15th
please come back anytime any time on the
show I appreciate you saying that Tyson
fury at Tyson underscore fury on Twitter
and gipsy.king 101 on Instagram right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app